c'est le jeu de l'abaisser mais version
touche pas à mon poste c'est très simple
vous allez faire équipe avec dorothée
vous allez faire équipe avec moi ariane
vous allez faire équipe avec jean michel
maire jacky vous allez faire équipe avec
bertrand chamerois et enora avec qorbi
on va regarder à quoi ressemblait le jeu
à l'époque et on va le faire dans un
instant jean-michel enora et je bertrand
allez vous mettre en place c'est parti
nous allons pour jouer au jeu de l'apc
avec antonio à l'eau alors tu vas bien
où tu es prêt oui lequel tu veut arroser
en fait je vais essayer la rose est en
tout cas je peux le témoin fait la
droite ou micro en main qui tient chaque
revers du deux roues
et
ça c'était pour montrer on allait partir
en tournage vacances et on ne pouvait
pas emporter toute la machinerie
non mais t'es toute la machinerie donc
ça c'était le coq ou de doux qui était
en silence était bien mais c'était bien
le dire parce que même moi j'étais pas
bien moi je dis c'est pas tout à fait la
bc du ca alors qu'il est y regarder il
saute en duplex regardez les gonda donc
enora bertrand ça me roy ya ma place
juste à la version 8
il y aura un saut juste au dessus 1c'est
rsa jeunes est donc poser la première
question à ariane
oui ariane si vous répondez bien rien ne
se passera rien pour jean michel maire
si vous répondez mal il pourra arriver
l'option sur la zone 3 qui la question
oui pour quelle série est apparu pour la
première fois justin un toute première
fois c'était dans salut les musclés dans
salut les musclés jodoigne vous êtes
sûrs ou pas en fait sur la note ici je
suis c'est bien c'est la bonne réponse
il savait pas
c'est maintenant jacky avec bertrand
chamerois d'accord d'or
conan combien de soi peut-on entendre le
mot fou dans le générique du dessin
animé le collège fou fou fou
je prends les caisses c'est un truc de
fou tout d'abord passer sa voix c'est le
collège cheverus d'âcre et aux hasards
64e 60 68 x et non c'est beaucoup moins
ces trottoirs vacances à mon adresse toi
voici voici la question pourrait n'aura
voici la question pour enora et laura va
c'est la question pour vous quel membre
des muscles et apporte ce dos le nom
d'une banane on me dit que c'est pas
cette question c'est combien
quel est le nom du réalisateur oui c'est
cambistes est vrai même l'envié vous
jouez avec enora cambier vase et
attention on s'en fout attention voici
la question oui oui vas-y il assure le
quai sur n'importe quel est le nom du
réalisateur des épisodes 74 74
de quoi est ce une échoppe biais du
zodiaque toi japonais oui c'est je peux
vous donner il faut vous donner le
prénom
kazuhito 15,8 au livre auto non c'est
kazuhito kikuchi attendaient leur
attendaient leur à doha on va vous
donner deuxième chose que cela a été
difficile mais on va se donner une
deuxième chance
attention la voici dans le miel et les
abeilles
quelle comédienne joue le rôle de marie
neige une comédien ouais pas de
comédienne dans ses sièges et le lundi
c'est
c'était nathalie diba hainaut est pris
plein la gueule
merci n'aura à merci logiciel attention
ça va être ta voix rien et encore ça va
être à moi
riga alors la question je vais je vais
vous la posez les peines imposées à
dorothée à vous à québec je vais aller
là choisir là bas ont choisi de nous la
question non non je vais la choisir une
enquête démarre je reviens à vous
inquiétez pas je vais à soi dire
attention je vais mettre en place
allez-y
tout mouillé alors qu'est ce que vous
entendez noté oui j'ai besoin d'un
nouveau test vous m'entendez je vous
entends sais rien je vois si la question
restant inscrits sur facile car le
dessin animé olive et tom qui marque des
buts ou tom olive et tom voix non non
non y en a qu'un qui marque des buts
avons commandé mais je sais ça moi il
m'a dit je volais vous tombe à votre
album give you lie au libouli oliveira
je vais vous dire c'était pas ça les
métros se perdre
c'était c'était tom il est gardien de
but
et le mas côté j'ai mis à compter mais
c'est pas grave dorothée merci vous avez
gagné